[Music]
there's a clear double
standard between the left and the right
behavior that you only see on the left
and not the right if you need further
proof that there's a double standard
that the left is brainwashed society
looked no
further than florida the fraud going on
in florida
as an acceptable solution to our
election
process is the last straw
after four days are the same two
counties that we've repeatedly had
trouble with in the past
still able to say their election is not
final
how is that possible how is that okay
as i speak to you florida's secretary of
state has officially declared a recount
for governor and united states senator
in florida
on election night though both
republicans were declared the winners
over their democrat opponents
republican rick scott was declared the
winner over democrat bill
nelson for florida's u.s senate seat
republican congressman ron desantis
was declared winner against democrat
andrew gillum a local mayor
but tonight everything is in flux
democrat gillum the loser candidate who
conceded
on election night has just today
officially pulled back his concession to
republican ron desantis
so what's going on the democrats are
refusing to accept the declared results
of the national media
theirs is a double standard you say we
lost
we'll say we won and in the words of dnc
lawyer mark elias an operative from
clinton
fusion gps christopher steele fraudulent
dossier
intended also to disenfranchise
us on a national presidential election
we'll do a recount and
we will win
so how do they do this lo and behold
they find
missing ballots and where do they find
these ballots
in deep blue counties run by democrats
in florida broward and palm beach
now broward and palm beach counties may
sound familiar to you because in 2000
there was a hand recount
in palm beach county because the
democrats didn't want to accept the
results of a presidential election
in 2006 there was another recount
started by the democrats
in 2016 another recount and in 2018
another recount in the same two
counties now folks there are 3
141 counties and county equivalents
in the united states so you tell me
how 3139 counties
can get their votes in 30 minutes after
the polls close
but not these two the other counties get
it right
there's even a county that suffered a
category four hurricane in florida
that was able to turn in their ballots
30 minutes after the election
but the same two deep blue
democrat control counties in florida
where republicans won in the two most
important races
can't get their act together but it's
not the first time
there's one person who seems to be at
the center of this a miss brenda snipes
the election supervisor in broward
county
shown here now you may know about brenda
because in 2016 a judge called her
out for destroying ballots that
benefited her friend
debbie wasserman schultz so election
night broward reports
thousands of votes 634 thousand
and now there are reportedly thousands
more votes
you're kidding right a primer every
county is supposed to hand in
all early voting and absentee ballots
within 30 minutes of the polls closing
most counties already count those
ballots before election night
but now in a lawsuit brought against ms
snipes
governor scott argues that snipes is
refusing to comply with a campaign
request for voter and ballot information
at an emergency hearing yesterday in
florida the governor asked the court to
have
miss snipes turn over records detailing
how she counts
and collects ballots snipes as might be
expected
is refusing to turn over the records
saying
it's inappropriate for a court to
intervene
this time simply because scott wants the
counting process sped up
what is even more outrageous is that
after snipes destroyed ballots
illegally in the 2016 election
her that her premature destruction of
the ballots under court review
in a pending lawsuit was described as
unlawful
and in violation of the public records
act
that court in 2016 cited a similar case
where the individual was dismissed
saying dismissal under these
circumstances
is an appropriate sanction but the court
went even beyond saying that about
snipes
they said her violation was two-fold
number one
snipes violated state and federal
retention requirements
and number two snipes violated the
affirmative responsibility
to preserve evidence why was this woman
not
fired yet today miss snipes lives on
to mess up yet another or overturn
yet another election in florida and if
that's not enough to infuriate you
after the court's decision about miss
snipes
the state of florida announced it would
be monitoring
broward's 2018 election
now let me tell you what a mess we're in
there are reportedly
thousands of new found ballots each one
is five pages long
do you think a woman who doesn't tally
or canvas along the way
who loses thousands of ballots who
doesn't want to turn them in
in 30 minutes after the polls are closed
like
3139 other counties do
should be trusted do you think she
should be allowed to view
five times because that's how long the
ballots are
five pages of thousands and thousands of
missing ballots folks this is lunacy
voter fraud is insidious it causes
people to think their vote doesn't
matter
but it's worse than that folks there are
reportedly transcripts now
that prove that when the democrats say
they want
every vote counted they mean it
yes that's what i said but
it's not just your votes it's illegals
votes that some lawyers in these
canvassing hearings for democrats want
counted
a report out today says lawyers for
democrats gillum
and nelson are objecting to the
rejection of
votes cast by non-citizens so when the
lawyer for the democrats
mark elias famous for his role in the
dossier creation that was an attempt to
disenfranchise
our duly elected president says he's
going down to florida to win
he should have added by any means
that's my open if you love my opening
statements you love my new book new york
times number one bestseller
liars leakers and liberals the case
against the anti-trump conspiracy